what's up buddy hi how you doing what's
up
hey
I'm okay
um I always want to get your take
um the what uh advice would you have for
somebody that basically I've been on
this like a long journey and I've been
trying to become like it's been kind of
up and down but I'm trying to become
best version of myself like uh you know
with everything with you know masculine
Alpha being leader and being the right
type of person and I've been I've real
have a realization I've joined this
program I've worked with a few words I'm
doing this program now it's like a long
three-week program to try basically try
to get the skills everything because
it's a skill set but for some what
advice would you ever someone that's
like a regular you know with I'm not
really great at flirting and teasing
with women my game is very is pretty
basic with the social script what's the
what's the course that you got sorry uh
modern flirting program modern flirting
and who offers that uh it's uh Jared
psych Lawrence
okay was that like a pickup artist or
something uh they yeah it's called My
they have a group and stuff and he's got
like it's basically it's a whole
in-depth thing from girls from like
dating and to like learn uh Social
Circle how to be a social influencer
okay
what do you do for a living right now
um I do like uh delivery like doordash
and Uber
okay
um and where do you live in what city uh
St Louis Missouri okay and sorry what's
your question like what's the ask here
oh well my question I just want to get
your advice on somebody who has basic
game structure basically and I want to
have the best like personality be cocky
funny tease and flirt with women because
I'm not great I have like just basic
conversation you know and I've been
I'm sorry how old are you uh I just
turned 35 uh November and how you doing
with the ladies right now like what's
your experience um I it's off and on I
get I've gotten so many numbers and
stuff and the majority of the time
though they like they flake or they say
you know I call them they say they call
me back they don't or something but I
mean it's like a mix with sometimes it's
good interaction sometimes it's not so
it's it's varied
um and I've approached like so many I've
been on this like okay I'm sorry go
ahead sorry I'm just gonna stop you so
my friend Chris is in the chat and he
says Jesus more woman [ __ ] step up
your lives guys chicks come with
Excellence now you're 35 you drive for
Uber and doordash
um and you're buying some pickup artists
course on Modern flirting do you see the
problem here and you're also overweight
I can see in your face no yeah no I'm
getting no I'm working on that yeah no I
know yeah so like are you seeing the
problem here
I'm like
you know what is the problem
um well I'm so that I know that you know
what the problem is
uh
it's why my look I'm gonna you know lose
weight and then I guess it's about like
who I am as a person or what I'm doing
with my life how tall my path and
purpose how tall are you and what do you
weigh uh five eight right now around 2
30.
five eight two thirty I you're you're
like 50 60 pounds overweight
yeah
and how much do you make driving Uber
and doordash
um a decent amount
four hundred thousand five hundred
thousand uh just no not that much not
extremely amount but just enough
to pay your rent yeah and you want to
get the girls at 35 doing it this way
uh I mean I'm just you know yeah have
you read my book
I haven't you should probably read my
book dude that's that's a better use
than spending money on the flirting
course or whatever the hell it is that
you bought
right like like you're thinking is laser
focused on getting the girls you've
bought a dumb course on how to get the
girls but none of IT addresses the fact
that you're overweight none of IT
addresses the fact that you're not uh
Rich which you should be by the time
you're 35 like
I'm guessing you like attractive women
yeah or do you prefer like single moms
that are overweight
no I mean just like any guy so you like
attractive women yeah so if you want the
attractive women then you're gonna have
to like level yourself up because 35
driving Uber and doordash overweight is
not going to get you the attractive
women I don't care how well you master
the manual swamp course on flirting with
dead girls
you're still like you might get a number
you might get a date you might escalate
it and go further than that but that's
it
but that's all you're ever gonna get
you're never going to have a woman
compliment your life she's never going
to be like oh Paul you're sick let me
come over and take care of you
oh I did actually the last woman I dated
wanted to come when my back was her and
she came over and brought me like sushi
she said would you wanna I wanted Sushi
yeah
attractive
she's older though I've been only able
to attract like older like church women
and stuff I'm trying to attract a
different type of social Church women so
what do you so what's older 50 60. uh
40s he was in her 40s yeah I don't think
you're telling me the truth man there's
no no I'm serious there's there's no
like show me a picture and I'll tell you
if she's attractive right because okay
she she is attractive Paul I want you to
to get off the manual swamp crap and how
to flirt with the girls and get the
numbers and get to the root of the
problem the root of the problem is
you're like over 50 pounds overweight
you're insignificant and you're not
interesting enough to get high quality
beautiful women in your life you don't
make enough money driving Uber and
doordash is not what women like there's
no woman out there that's right now
going you know what Becky yeah what's up
Karen
um went out the sky last night there was
a doctor but the dude that drove the
door Jazz and was 50 pounds overweight
like I'd rather have him
yeah but they say when you have land
right well no I understand it but
there's there I was watching real social
dynamics and basically how you're able
to be have a strong sense of reality and
able to be an influencer like that can
over Trump like basically the rich guy
who's because he was basically say an
example about an NBA like a guy Owen and
Julian yeah yeah they said that there
was a guy
[ __ ] idiots okay
like take a look in the mirror dude do
any of these women throw themselves at
you and want to spend extensive like are
you able to spin plates and have tons of
attractive women come at you okay
because that red-headed guy he's fat
he's out of shape I can't even remember
his name what's his name Owen Tyler yeah
Tyler called himself he's fat and out of
shape
where where is this beautiful woman of
his
the reason why he's got girls is because
he's got guys like you sending him money
he's conned you into thinking that you
can go and get the girls just by
flirting with them or being socially
influential
look look at the chat women smell fake
confidence dummy
well I'm saying it does help though a
guy who's rich and stuff can have a
shitty personality and weak game isn't
going to attract the majority of women
just because he throws money at or gives
her money he's gonna track the wrong
type of women too look dude dude look if
you want to go at this angle with I'm
gonna game them to getting their pants
off like I said you'll probably have a
little bit of success if you're really
good with game but you're a 35 year old
guy that's 50 pounds overweight doing
Uber and doordash
any chick that's hot in your radius I
would steal her from you in a second
and I'm older than you
any guy out there that's competent
interesting that has a captivating life
will steal her from you oh yeah so so
why are you trying to level yourself up
in an area that doesn't matter when
there's this broad spectrum in your life
that matters more because I don't want
to be boring and basic and be on social
scripts and have a baseline personality
to bore women to death and then because
I had women who you know used me to buy
drinks and then they walk away a few
minutes later they act like their
friends calling them and lying and it's
like I know because I wasn't you know
getting them engaged and getting their
emotions uh entangled you know wanting
to talk to me dude you're the you're the
typical guy that is drunk on the manual
swap Kool-Aid of [ __ ]
I'm dude I'm telling you straight up
look at the chat read the live comments
after the video right guys are watching
look look at it you're boring already
people are people already at you on this
dude
right like they're already at you on
this you're not listening I mean you got
influence over them that you have
influence over them and you have you
have status you're not listening to me
you haven't even read my damn book you
haven't even started with a ten dollar
book
okay and you're asking me about some
[ __ ] pickup artists flirty lines or
some [ __ ] course dude you've got your
priorities completely wrong
you are a plugged in beta male my friend
I wish I had some better news for you
but I look first call of 2023 we're
coming in with a carpet bombing here I
think Jared was in the live chat cold
cold hard truth bombs right over a
[ __ ] carpet bombing on this one Paul
the master
it should be Paul the masturbator my man
oh yeah I'll I'm the master of all
things I'm just playing no but uh I
appreciate you having me on uh it was a
pleasure sir my friend I am I am just
being honest with you I don't know
that's cool but I just call it like it
is and this is the cold hard truth that
you need to hear I know you don't want
to hear it but this is the cold hard
truth that you need to hear so I I focus
on fixing your health focus on fixing
your sources of income make them more
significant and free like the game
part's easy look I'm sure you've got
game because if you're talking to girls
and girls will responding to you even
though you're 30 35 overweight not doing
much with your life as far as making
money because it's just good enough
you've got game don't worry about the
game Parts everybody who has two women
and he he lives with each one of them
and he gets rides off of him and he's a
drug dealer and stuff show me the
pictures of them
I don't I mean it's on my like social I
don't want to show you know what I'm
saying okay but I mean you know it what
I'm saying is if you have a life if you
have a woman you want to argue with me
you just want to no I don't know I think
that your ways the right way but read
the live chat read the comments
afterwards don't don't take it from me
okay these guys are not my paid
employees they're just smarter than you
are and they're also pointing to the
facts as well
this is this is a very very obvious
thing
I want you to take this to heart and
focus on the self-care focus on fixing
your money you already have game you
don't need extra game if you're talking
to girls if women are you know
responding to you you can get phone
numbers you've got enough game fix the
other [ __ ]
that's where you're going sideways
oh because I mean dude like 10 15 years
you're a couple of cheeseburgers away
from a heart attack or a stroke if
you're carrying 50 50 extra pounds at
five foot eight
straight up diabetes diabetic
pre-diabetic it's coming for you my
friend
yeah all right no I was actually in a
better weight I went through a lot of
stuff I was a hospital so I just I had a
lot of ups and downs over these years
and things that happened to me so forget
about the game part
turn off the [ __ ] real social
dynamics turn off whatever that [ __ ]
goof was that sold you that flirting
course you don't you already know how to
flirt
work on the other stuff that is all and
read my damn book
read my book before you come on the show
guys thanks
holy smokes
holy smokes
man I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out